it's time choose your weapon carts and  Broncos I guess they have some weapons  but the general will the eatos destroy  grid iron Heights we'll all of the  marketable stars finally escape vir were  you I'm David Johnson the number one  fantasy running back to 2016 what will  the Vikings do at quarterback there's  only one contract for the Pens are eight  and you're injured knees will Blake  bortles leave the exit fails Alabama  Americans to the super slam smack ball  where in the world is Andrew Luck are  you here for the arms deal this is gonna  be okay we'll Pat Sherman be seduced by  the Big Apple and which quarterback will  be drafted into the upside Brown get out  find out next season on gridiron Heights